we're doing the scene and I realize I'm
30 feet underwater
and that's how we do these scenes we put
emotional scenes in a big tank
With No SCUBA we will learn how to free
dive this great technique how long can
you hold your breath underwater uh well
Kate Winslet did seven minutes going
into about six I did easy 15 seconds
so your scenes are very quick uh no but
it was that the thing was you when
you're under that deep you have to
forget that you're under the water and
these scenes are hard enough to do in
dry land and we're just crazy enough to
put them under underwater you can hear
Jim under the water too so he directs
you through these sound systems in the
tank they would bring the scuba over on
cup and I wouldn't come up it was easier
for me to stay down there because it was
a long way up so I would just spend
hours down there and the rest of the the
camera team is down there with you and
safety coordinators and but I would just
do my breathe UPS under the water it was
quite calm yeah oh my gosh you just
really live you're coming out like a
prune